so it was World kindness day yesterday  um today's my birthday and I think they  should move it a day because my mom  really instilled that [ __ ] in me but  this headline really has me hyped for my  video for this evening  people really confused out here a lot of  people are upset  upset happy and they don't realize one  of the reasons that is  they themselves are not nice enough you  want to be [ __ ] happier have this  crazy ass concept maybe if you take the  offense  and actually are more kind more often  bringing more love to more people people  that are close to you random [ __ ]  strangers if you just start going out of  your [ __ ] way to be kind miraculously  you become a happier person too many  glass half empty [ __ ] on the  Earth  how about really understanding how this  game's actually played make this moment  the second you deploy [ __ ] kindness  and happiness it'll change your life